le conseil scientifique s'est exprimée
en donnant une estimation je parle bien
d'une estimation parce que si vous posez
la question à tous les membres du
conseil scientifique personne n'est
capable de vous dire avec précision si
le confinement doit être de temps de
telles durées de tête dure et ils ont
dit il faut peut-être se préparer à ce
que le confinement dure au delà de 15
jours nous le savons mais peut-être qui
pourrait s'étendre jusqu'à une date plus
lointaine de l'ordre de cinq ou six
semaines
encore une fois grande prudence n'ont
pas qu'on n'ait pas envie d'avertir les
français que le confinement serait
amenée à durer mais parce que cette
réponse nous ne l'avons pas nous sommes
là dans des estimations qui sont fondés
sur des avis des expertises
il y à d'autres expertises qui ne sont
pas forcément dans ce conseil
scientifique il ya d'autres expertises
parmi les nombreux pays qui ont déjà mis
en place du confinement et qui disent en
fait on ne saura quand on pourra lever
le confinement que lorsque la courbe
épidémique le permettra c'est le
principe de base
le confinement il a une vocation
protéger les français tant qu'il devra
durer il durera si nous avons la
possibilité de lever le confinement plus
tôt nous le ferons évidemment il n'y a
pas de raison de poursuivre dans la
durée
mais encore une fois je comprends les
questions les interrogations
l'impatience parfois l'anxiété
c'est tout à fait normal et
compréhensible nous apportons toutes ses
réponses en transparence à mesure que
les données lui reviennent c'est un dur
pour ce ce principe de transparence que
nous avons rendu public cet avis du
conseil scientifique mais attention
encore une fois ce n'est pas un avis
ferme ce n'est pas et personne ne vous
dira au sein du conseil scientifique
c'est une prédiction qui sera auto
réalisatrice il s'agit d'une estimation
parmi d'autres